has tu nous avais parlé d'un pompier oui
qu'est ce qui se passe avec ce pompier
tu pour compte depuis le début alors
c'est un pompier qui dit à sa femme
écoute on va faire comment la caserne
quand je te dise si rennes 1 tu te
déshabille parce que des sirènes de tu
sautes d'anlier et quand je dis si
rennes 3 on y va pour la nuit
donc le soir venu ils crient ciel 1 elle
se dévêtit la faune sedan lycienne de et
plonge dans le lit sir l3 et commence à
faire l'amour au bout de deux minutes
est la crise irène 4,6 à leucate il dit
mais qu'est ce qui se passe c'est quoi
si rennes 4 à lui dire ajoute du tuyau
tu es trop loin du feu la c1 à rabat un
français un américain qui se battent sur
une page sur une plage y croise un génie
il en bo3 en génie et le génie leur dit
vous allez chacun votre tour lancé
quelque chose dans l'océan
si je le retrouve je vous tue deux sur
le coup après sont pas nicole génie dias
ouais mec sans paniquer tout est dit
[ __ ] c'est pas possible et où le
français commence qui fouille dans sa
poche se trouve une toute petite tour
est fait comme ça
il lance la plus petite tour eiffel en
plein milieu de l'océan le génie va y
chercher chercher chercheurs y trouve la
petite tour eiffel il arrive vite eu le
français les deux ils sont comme ça ils
sont sous le choc
comment on va faire on va faire à
l'américaine voilà ce qu'il faut dans sa
poche et trouve un petit cours d'eau
comme ça il jette le petit kurdes en
plein milieu de l'océan
le génie cherche y cherche y cherchent
ils cherchent les troubles ou petite
cure dents y vas y tu l'américain et as
l'arabe dans sa poche comme ça il jette
quelque chose en plein milieu de l'océan
le génie cherche y cherche et cher
richert s'y trouve pas il revient avoir
leur avis mais qu'est ce que tu as jeté
barabé d'image jeter un efferalgan
[Applaudissements]
ça démarre fort très très bonne ça c'est
un char assiste donc et qui est très
très raciste et qui décident d'aller
contre ces préjugés
donc il dit bon allez cheval à la
mosquée peut-être que c'est pas comme je
pense peut-être que voilà il y un cheval
à la mosquée d'où qui va à la mosquée le
vendredi tous il s'assoit avec nous il
enlève ses chaussures et et comment si
c'est le discours de l'imam comment
c'est tout il se sent petit peu quand
même apaisé spirituellement il ne pense
pas mal et tout est l'imam marche dans
les rangs comme ça va le voir et lui mes
amants sur le front comme ça et lui dit
tu vas marché alors hassisidi mais
attendez je comprends pas j'ai pas le
problème de motricité moi je vais
marcher je comprends pas la prière
commence la prière finie sort et ils
voient qu'on lui a volé sa voiture
[Rires]
c'est une famille qui m'a dans un camp
nudiste et le petit garçon il demande à
son papa il y parlera pourquoi il ya des
hommes qui ont des gros zizi et pourquoi
il ya d'autres hommes qui ont des petits
zizis son pays bas écoute c'est ça je
vais t'expliquer tous les hommes qui ont
un petit zizi sont pauvres et tous les
hommes qui ont un gros zizis sont riches
il lui dit ah ok mais pourquoi tu me
pose cette question il dit parce que
tout à leur maman parlé avec un monsieur
très très pauvres qui est devenu très
très riches en cinq minutes
et là le père il est très inquiet lui
dit m'attend mais une question a raconté
l uta merle a eu dix ans mais t'inquiète
pas papa est là en train de lui sucer
tout son pognon là c'est un arabe et un
gitan qui rentre dans une boulangerie de
ses deux copains donc c'est un arrache
toi qui rend dans une boulangerie et il
y en a 1 boulangerie et la ra prend 1
tweaks très très vite et le met dans sa
poche et regarde les huit ans comme si
l'état lui la classe et justin lui dit
attendons juste montrer c'est quoi la
classe c'est nous les gitans c'est nous
les meilleurs jeux idiots qu'est le jt
regarde la boulangère comme ça il
devrait moins tweak s'il vous plaît à
lui donner un tricks il ouvre le cucs
comme ça et mangent les tweaks et
regarde la boulangère tu il la fixe en
régime en jeu il finit son tweaks
hermange le deuxième le deuxième il
reprend il mange de deuxième alors comme
ça a du bon c'est assez duré c'est quoi
le tour de magie
il dit maintenant regarder dans la poche
de l'arabe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout